[Music]
so something that came up during the
Leviathan po treat little idea is
this repeating something over and over
again is not necessarily good practice
uh it's just repeating something over
and over again what I mean by that is uh
is this we'll take an example say say
you just learned the backward 5 be weave
um and you want it to be nice and clean
but it's looking more like
this so this a chance that if you just
keep playing with it keep repeating it
that you will slowly make it cleaner and
cleaner and that in a week it will be a
nice clean backward 5T weave and then
you can go from a forward 5T weave and
get all that hang
time into a backward 5 weave in back
Etc but often that's not what happens
often people will take a they just
learned a move and they don't like how
it looks and they'll repeat it and
repeat it and repeat it but it won't get
better at that point all that repetition
begins to be a problem because you're
ingraining what you don't want into your
muscle memory cuz if you take something
like say a backward weave that looks
like this and repeat it um 10,000
times that'll be extra your ingrained
way of doing it so if you play with
something a little bit after a little
while ask yourself is it
improving if it is great you can just
keep playing but if it's not
improving I recommend breaking it down
into pieces so that you can work on it
where you can see that it is
improving so with a backward pement
weave I would do this I would say well
first off
let's I think an important part of that
move is how the wrists move together so
I would say go to one Po and for a
little while really just work on how are
your wrists curling around each other
are they really snaking around each
other really wrist to
wrist like you're doing a hand
dance when you've got that with one
POI maybe go to two POI but start just
backwards split time and just take a
side and say okay my right's going to
come snake on my
left and just repeat that just that part
around my
left around my left one of my favorite
longterm tips is being able to Loop that
part loop as a two be weave that's a
really good way to get really smooth
with the five be weaves so if you see
some improvement with the right or on
the left also do the Le or on the right
and make the reason I think it's good
just to start from split time is then
you can really see just one part of the
pattern boom now doing this I can almost
guarantee you you'll be able to see
Improvement if you just take a piece and
just work on a piece it's like taking
apart your car engine and just working
on the part that's not
working and when you've seen Improvement
on both sides go back to the full
pattern and see if it's
improved so almost always
uh working on the pieces results in
Faster progress than working on the on
the whole move um take it with a grain
of salt but often it's often the way I
practice another great example is I was
recently working on with my fire poy
thinking I want to be able to do a spir
up around one hand be able to catch the
PO at the end so I can freeze you know
all majestically and
unspin but wasn't quite working I was uh
wrapping and it wasn't I wasn't quite
able to catch the final Po and for a
little while I was doing it over and
over and realized okay I'm not getting
anywhere then I realized I'm not even
sure the PO that I'm almost
catching is is that my left po or my
right
po so I had to unwind
them okay it's the left po that I'm
almost catching and it wasn't going far
enough then I realized okay it's all
it's it's all about the length uh of
this PO that I give around this hand
whether I am sort of away from it or
close or really going further will
determine whether that PO lands in my
hand or not or
not so then I you know I knew what to do
so I was like okay so what I need to do
is give it a little more room and then I
can catch it so once I stopped realized
I wasn't making
progress you know looked more close at
what I was doing determined what I might
need to change then I was able to make
progress so uh that's you know those are
just some examples towards the general
philosophy if you're working on
something if you're not clearly seeing
you're making some progress then uh
change what you're doing break it down
break into its pieces figure out what
bit you can work on or what needs to
change and you will see a lot more uh
progress so I hope this helps um I uh I
like making these videos for you uh I
would like to say again check out my
online courses or my new
patreon.com uh campaign um those are
great ways to support me if you would
like to see me keep making videos like
this and come join us here at Levan
Studio next year because it's a lot of
[Music]
fun that one was pretty
good good
[Music]